sketche oder ist immer schön wenn man
auch einmal etwas glück nichts bekommen
bayern video ich habe mein bruder wieder
dabei und zwar das gibt es öfter schon
auf youtube aber ich bin es weniger
wichtig beziehungsweise gpk passig und
zwar dass dieses extrem smoothie
challengers wir haben jetzt hier zehn
sachen ausgesucht die sind nicht ganz so
krass aber wenn es zu krasse sachen
werden im körper ist einfach nicht
trinken und deswegen haben wir uns
gedacht dann machen was ein bisschen
unspektakuläre aber versuchen es
wirklich zu trinken man mal sehen ob
verschaffen
auf jeden fall wasser ketchup senf salz
und in kakaopulver auf jeden fall
wünscht viel spaß beim gefällt es auf
jeden fall noch um nach wird uns sehr
freuen
und jetzt viel spaß mit dem video das
die ganzen teile die wir ziehen müssen
abwechseln werden jetzt bei
unterschiedlichen becher da kommen
parteien kommt er seine sachen legen
oder in meinen kommen meine sachen rein
und wir fangen einfach mal ein
jobwechsel oder was man einfach
schnecken schlag
okay das erste beschreibt das ist ja man
geht ja noch
ich weiß nicht ich jeder rein soll aber
so viele gibt's davon oder wasser er
bleibt seiner projekte
weil hier geht das wäre erst möglich
wenn auch irgendwie salz- oder so du
bist als thema haben wir sie schon mal
getrunken weiß nicht in welcher er
versammelt
das ist schon aber eigentlich
kakaopulver okay das wird also ich weiß
nicht ob mir das glaubt aber da ist ganz
viel kakao zucker
ich schon nicht salz sind ist noch
wichtiger als das letzte
ich würde sagen das weich oder ist es
wirklich so raus so hat er jetzt das
letzte workshop bei jedem wisst was
gabriels gesehen haben die anzahl direkt
aus gekommen
es ist witzig aber das bringt ja nicht
so viele
wir versuchen dass man was ich 100 mix
erheben
ja also das hier war jetzt berlins geht
irgendwie komisch aus bisher nachschauen
oder so war das recht auf jeden fall
nach ketchup und sind so jetzt vom 1
das riecht nach sich selbst ich das so
wir wollen das jetzt eben noch ein zwei
gläser will macht man einfach schick
schlug wann fängt am besten wider
guck mal das ist so richtig man sieht so
diesen selbst da drinnen sowie das
erkennen da sind sogar bestücken
wenn ich das wenn ich das trinke ja okay
leute ich würde sagen wir machen wir
schnell schnick schnack schnuck wert
hängt und ich habe angst war das richtig
auf jeden fall
233 ich probiere einfach ich will nicht
endlich konstant ein was wir an einem
reichhaltigen trinkt einfach denke ich
so aleker cola trinkt solchen hand
gehalten aber die trinkst als einem
halben jahr mache ich habe verleihen ich
habe hier ohne scheiß richtig angst
nicht schuldig
fast schon schlecht
ich hab so angst natürlich ist dieser
sendung
es ist alles voll okay bis auf dem
senders in zucker mehl salz meine ich
das so ähnlich eine sendung ist ja schon
eklig aber man schmeckt auch noch so
richtig dieses salz weißt du weil keine
ahnung beschränkt so richtig salzig und
senf zwei stücke kaum einer
sollte das auch ausprobiert so aus
die geschmäcker das war das schmeckt
einfach nur dieses typs et ketchup und
salz das ist das ekligste was man
zusammen mischen kann und es heißt das
werk einfach nur noch selber und salz
und das nach ketchup und zimt soll ein
ich würde sagen wir belassen das erstmal
bis dahin ich hab jetzt ungefähr so die
hälfte getroffen er zwei drei stücke ist
ja voll okay aber und wenn ihr bock habt
macht doch mal ein video machte wasser
rein und seid und schickt mir das und
ohne scheiß ist es möglich wenn ihr wenn
ihr das macht und außerdem ziehe ich
ziehe ich den hut für euch und dann
natürlich sagen jetzt nochmal der
instagram ein event könnt ihr mal
vorbeischauen wenn die lok und ansonsten
sehen uns montag schon wieder um 15 uhr
montags freitags 8.30 und ich würde
sagen abonnieren nie vergessen und mich
dazu verpassen
ihr auf der linken seite also hier geht
es weiter mit einem video das war ein
follow me rock folgen berlin und auf der
anderen seite mit dem letzten jahr von
der freien das war keine ahnung hat auf
jeden fall euch an und wir sehen uns mal
wieder sein